this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life
and your money my name is anthony
o'neill host of the popular youtube
and podcast show the table with anthony
o'neil and co-hosting
with me today is number one national
best-selling author
of business boutique has some amazing
things going on host of the christy
wright show
um and killing the game especially
around ladies and
uh starting a business like christy
what's up hey this is going to be fun
you and i get feisty i'm pretty excited
about this oh this is going to be so
good so
this is like we haven't done this this
year have we no no
y'all get ready fasten your seatbelts
two people who who love each other who
also love to talk
so uh we have two speeds a sleep or a
hundred miles an hour there's no in
between
there is no in between with us you know
we're gonna talk real fast we're gonna
get straight to the question
uh and we're gonna be very honest you
know and so if you have a question about
your life
about your money if you want to start a
business
um there's this is a one woman
appreciation month or woman
acknowledgement month or something like
that
um and so we have a woman uh who really
loves
helping ladies accomplish their goals
their dreams starting businesses
and so i want you to give us a call
christy wright is the i say she's the
queen really she's the king but she's a
woman so she's the queen in this space
and so give us a call at 825-5225
that's triple eight
a conversation with you uh let's get
straight to the phone let's do it i love
it
so let's go out to uh my home state
north carolina raleigh north carolina
uh good afternoon rory how can christie
and i help man
hey guys how are you guys doing doing
all right
hey so i had a quick question uh i'm
currently 18 years old i just moved out
of my parents house on monday
okay i'm in school part-time at a
community college
and i i was just offered an internship
with amazon
and it's going to be 15 15 months it'll
be
paid and i'm cash flowing college i'm
paying for everything
and i was just wondering where i should
get started with the baby step
oh man rory this is good now uh what
community college are you going to there
in raleigh
uh wake tech lake technical community
college absolutely yeah i know i know
all about wake tech man i was going to
go to a fayetteville tech
in fayetteville north carolina about an
hour and a half away from there so i
know exactly where you're going how much
is amazon paying you man for these
uh next 18 months uh it's gonna be
twenty dollars an hour uh 40 hours a
week
what's the point of some money brother
that's what i'm talking about
okay any any debt do you have right now
do you have any credit cards
uh no sir i'm completely debt free it's
it's a uh it's a robotic
internship they just built a warehouse
here and i'm studying mechatronics so
cool yeah that's awesome
i love it i love it well you know
chrissy i think the very first thing
rory should do is really just skip over
baby step two
um and really just start saving your
three to six months rory you're a young
man you just moved out on your own
and so what i want you to do is i want
you to sit down and get on an every
dollar budget okay rory
what you're going to do is you're going
to list all of your income which is
going to be your amazon check
um if you're driving for uber eats if
you're doing anything extra i want you
to list all your income
then i want you to list all your
expenses so this is going to be you know
your rent this is going to be
you know if you have an iphone or
android phone any apps you're paying for
um you're a young man so i'm pretty sure
you're single so if you out dating you
need to have a line item for dating okay
um so you got to get creative list all
your expenses i don't know why young
people out here laughing at me i know
that's real
i see y'all laughing at me uh but you
know you got to put everything on there
so you can have control over your money
that's the key thing that i really want
you to understand rory you're gonna
start with baby step number three
and baby set number three is gonna be
three to six months of your living
expenses
okay and you're gonna do that by getting
on every dollar
budget and that's the first place where
i would say start
but the key thing is man once you get
that three to six months rory if you can
do that by the end of this year and
start investing next year you'll be 19.
if you can start investing 15 of your
income roy but before you turn 50 you're
going to be a multi-millionaire
just by doing the bear basics uh so i
mean i love it i mean
here's the cool thing rory the fact that
you're asking this question
at 18 you gonna be okay like it
most 18 year olds are not asking this
question not calling the ramsay show
and not cash flowing their college you
are doing
awesome you're asking the right
questions you're already set up for
success the one
caution i would give you if you take
this internship
which sounds like an awesome opportunity
you're about to have
some money and when you got some money
you know what it does
it wants to burn a hole in your pocket
because you're like oh i'm living good i
got all this money it feels like so much
and just like anthony's telling you
don't lose focus of your goals and your
plan just because you got a little cash
in your pocket it'll be very tempting
to overspend that so just be aware of
that stick to your plan and you're going
to be just fine that's awesome
man listen hearing those calls what so
cool yeah i was not asking that question
at 18. 18.
do you know what i was doing at 18
mistakes i made some mistakes
listen here listen here man i was like
do i get another t-shirt for that credit
card where do i sign
sign me right on yeah i had to pay for
my mistakes in my 20s
i'm thinking about t-shirts uh free
pizza
the ladies it's free money y'all
no it's not no it's not no it's really
not man so rory
man take my hats off to you thank you so
much for calling in you are a true
example of what
uh most 18 year olds what most young
people need to be doing is thinking
about their future
and so thank you for asking that
question and make sure to check out with
me um
over on my show man i'm really gearing
my show towards a younger audience so
come over there to the table with your
boy anthony o'neil youtube podcast
and i'm gonna show you how to keep the
bag um and really build some more wealth
man i love it let's keep the
conversation going
uh triple eight eight two five five two
two five ramsey personalities anthony
o'neil and christy writer in the
building today
um and we're looking forward to having a
good show with you we're gonna go out to
richmond virginia and have a
conversation with matthew
uh good afternoon matthew uh real
quickly what's your question
hi there uh thanks for taking my call
yeah
so so the question is my wife and i have
saved up a
bit of money money over the last few
years we now have enough for our first
house
the problem is we don't know if we
should actually
buy our first house buy an investment
property
or hold off until we figure out where we
go next with uh with our family
okay in new york city the plan is to go
to um the west coast closer to family
but
you know with all the markets and
everything going on but just
we don't know what the next move is and
yeah maybe you can help us out a little
bit
yeah so are you do you plan on moving
within the next three years
uh within the next three months oh yeah
so then we're not buying nothing
yeah yeah so so here's the thing um i
don't want you to buy anything
until you know you're gonna be in this
city
for at least three to five years bare
minimum is three the ideal situation is
five
um but if you're moving within the next
three months no don't
don't buy anything because you don't
want to be a
long distance landlord because you won't
be able to watch it
and really take care of it and then for
me personally
i'm going to buy a house actually and
live in a house before i go out and get
some rental property so put your family
into a good home
then start talking about how to generate
some more income that's good i like it
that's good it's good yup chrissy right
anthony o'neil right here
on the ramsay show and we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
christy wright
author of business boutique co-hosting
with fellow ramsey personality anthony
o'neil and anthony i'm so excited
because
we get to have a conversation with
someone that i
absolutely love jamie kern lima is the
founder of
it cosmetics who recently sold to
l'oreal for a
billion dollars so just a small
accomplishment in her life
and she has a new book called believe it
how to go from underestimated to
unstoppable jamie how are you
christy i'm so good thank you so much
for having me here
how fun is this that i get to talk to
you on the ramsay show with anthony we
were just talking about you off air and
how amazing
you are jamie i know so much of your
story i had the honor of having you
speak at business boutique last year
i've had you on the christy wright show
but for anyone listening that isn't
familiar with you would you just tell us
a little bit about
your story and your new book believe it
yeah you know i'm probably most well
known for going from
denny's waitress to uh creating a dream
in my living room and going after it
and and building that to it cosmetics
which is now one of the largest uh
luxury makeup companies in the country
and then selling it to l'oreal but uh
the reason i wrote believe it christy is
um you know every single day i hear from
so many people saying
oh congrats on you know your fairy tale
but i'm struggling or i'm getting
rejected or my dreams not getting off
the ground
and i realize if we don't ever share
like the real stories behind the stories
um then everyone feels alone in their
own setbacks and gets tempted to give up
and
everything else so believe it it's
really a book about
overcoming self-doubt um what to do
when you're not getting the kind of
traction or or
or success that you're hoping for when
people like look you in the eye and tell
you you're not enough
what do you do in those situations um
because my real story is you know three
years of having everyone say no
uh with it cosmetics and uh eventually
turning those nose into yeses but it was
a really long road
um really filled with a lot of
self-doubt and it's really it's really
how do you go from not believing in
yourself to believing in yourself and
i think it's not just my story it's a
story of so many people out there right
now
especially coming out of a hard season
right of 14 months and
a lot of people have been dimming their
own light and this is a book that
hopefully will help everyone
ignite their light again and learn to
believe in themselves and the
possibility of their own dream
i love that and i love your story
because one of the things that's really
cool about this book anthony is she has
so many stories that you would never
know if she didn't tell it and jamie you
shared some of these stories on stage
at business boutique but i think that
people would easily look at someone like
you
and think well she just she's an
overnight success
she just magically appeared on the
mountaintop she's so
lucky all these extra things and you
tell story after story after story in
this book
of how you were looked in the face and
told no how you had to overcome
adversity overcome setbacks from
stories at qvc to trade shows where
you're literally
stalking people down the aisles trying
to get to the right person
to tell your story but you have this
even through all these stories and
setbacks
you have a tenacity you have a won't
take no for an answer
attitude and i think that that is
something so special about you would you
tell us like
where does that come from and how can
people that don't have that naturally
how can they do that too that that may
not come as
as naturally to be such a go-getter like
that
yeah i think you know everyone listening
to the three of us right now i feel like
all of us
know inside of god's like place a dream
on our heart or
maybe there's something in us that you
know we we have that inkling where we
know we need to create or
or or or launch the business or maybe
we're in the wrong job or the wrong
relationship we all kind of
have those feelings and you know i did a
lot of things wrong that i talked about
in the book but
but the biggest theme through the whole
book really and the things that i did
right was when i had that
feeling that knowing that internal
knowing
um i made the decision to trust it and
and i think that uh i think that so many
people
know if they're kind of made for more or
they're
you know have more to give or create or
they need to start painting again or
whatever it might be but they still
doubt themselves anyways and this
book is really about how do you break
through that that barrier of self-doubt
and step into really the person you're
born to be you know and and
yeah i was super super hard working and
super ambitious but
i think really this is what i believe i
believe
and that's why i love that you guys
share so many people's stories and so
many people that have success stories
through everything that you've done it
uh with with the ramsey companies
because when we see
other people's stories and we learn how
they got through it
that's when we like pull those stories
in when we can lean on them ourselves
um so yeah my book is really about of
course working hard and
not giving up and those kind of things
but really it's about how do you learn
how to believe in yourself
and trust yourself like hear your own
knowing and make the decisions
to trust it because i think that's
that's the ultimate success
um for all of us in our lives so james
let me ask you this question this is
anthony
good to meet you i i've seen you on uh
christy's stage and i'm like man she's
amazing
and i have a question we have a lot of
people who sometimes
do not believe in themselves they they
doubt their own self so they're scared
to experience some type of failure
to go to the next next level uh what was
one thing that you had to get over and
what what could you say to inspire
someone
uh to say you know what hey start
believing in yourselves start pushing
yourself forward what would you say to
that individual listening right now
yeah the first thing i'll say is like
i've now anthony had the blessing of
meeting
so many inspiring people that i never
could have imagined meeting
the first thing i've learned is they all
still struggle with self-doubt
so the first thing i'd say is you're not
alone anyone listening right now feels
like
oh i just don't believe in myself you're
not alone and i think that's
really important to know but also one
tool i would say is
really starting to take inventory of who
you let speak into your life
about your own dreams a lot of us i talk
in my book believe it about how to do
this in terms of like if you imagine you
have your own microphone
we all have our own microphone and
sometimes we hand our microphone over
to somebody who after we share our hopes
or our dreams or our situation with
we end up like you know self-doubt gets
bigger
right and sometimes it's our partner
sometimes it's our family
our friends people who love us but when
we share
our dreams or our hopes with them they
kind of see them through their
the lens of their own fear or their own
self-doubt
and so one thing i talk about in this
journey of building belief is
learning how to like take your
microphone back from some people in your
life you can love them
but talk to them about you know what's
going on with the weather and how it's
for dinner
but you know really curating the people
around you and people listening to
your radio show right now that's a way
for people to speak into people
about things that they want to do
whether it's get out of debt or go after
their dream right
curating who you hand your microphone to
who you take it back from
super important a lot of times we you
know
let everyone else's opinion gets so loud
that we
that we in our own self-doubt build that
we don't even hear
our own truth anymore so that's one of
many things
to do on the journey that i had to learn
how to do because anthony i was told no
so many times i was told no one will buy
makeup from someone who looks like you
with your body and your weight is what
one investor said when they passed on
investing
i was told you know i mean on and on and
on and i had to learn to turn down the
volume on that before it took
root in me and like turn up the volume
on my own knowing and
and and and people that spoke positivity
into my life
wow i love that because it's so
practical and and something
anybody can do now jamie before we go i
want to ask you one more question
because we talked about this on stage at
business boutique
you've shared this story on the christy
wright show and i know anthony's going
to love it so you are the epitome of
success
and you have a story about how you were
on the forbes richest wealth
you know self-made women list and you
didn't want to be on it
and after three years of them putting
you on it anyway you learned something
would you just real quick before we go
tell us something you learned about that
experience because i think it is such a
great lesson for men and women
as we um want to to chase our version of
success
yeah you know i did not when i got that
first phone call
because listen i i've been a denny's
waitress i have
been so scrappy and worked so hard my
whole life and when we eventually sold
our company to l'oreal
they announced the purchase price it was
all over the wall street journal
everywhere
so all of a sudden i find myself on the
on the forbes list and and the
name of the list is forbes richest
self-made women and i
was mortified i was embarrassed by it i
didn't want it to be shared and this was
this went on for three years until i had
this huge epiphany where i was like wait
a minute
so oh my gosh jamie i am so grateful for
your
story thank you for sharing with us
thank you for being a light i love how
you are just inspiring people
to believe in themselves this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five
five two two five this is the ramsay
show and ramsey personalities chrissy
wright and myself anthony o'neil
are with you on during this hour and on
the last segment man we have the
opportunity chrissy to interview one of
your friends
uh jamie who who's clearly a success
story oh my gosh
i'm like wow i kind of want to get her
on my show i'm like i need to talk
she needs her some more she's amazing
and what's so cool about her story from
starting this makeup company in our
living room to now having a
billion dollar company that sold to
l'oreal she just has this humble spirit
and she really wants people to believe
in themselves one of the things she
didn't mention when we talked to she's
donating all the proceeds from the book
she donated her time to be at business
boutique like she's just such a generous
giving person i could have talked to her
all day um but but i wanted you guys to
know you can get her book believeit
jamiekernlima.com or believeit.com and i
know she has an action plan and that
kind of thing i did want to tell you
anthony one story
that we didn't get to wrap up because
you'll find this fascinating so when
jamie was uh called to be interviewed to
be on the forbes richest
women list she didn't want to be on it
they were like we're going to we're
going to publish how much you make and
we're going to publish and she's like no
no no no no i
don't want to be on it this makes me
feel uncomfortable they said well we the
the records are public we're going to
put you on it like it or not and they
did
so they published about her year number
two same thing published her she's like
oh i feel so weird people know how much
my business is worth how much
you know i'm wearing all this stuff year
two they put her on there without her
having a quote year three i think it was
you're three or four they call her again
to get a quote
and so by year three or four she's like
all right
i think i'll i think i'll give a quote
like i think i'll actually like maybe
this could be a light for people to help
them see if i can do it
uh you know they can do it too and so
she decided well she's talking to the
interviewer the journalist and
she's i'm sorry it just makes me really
uncomfortable and the journalist said
all the women do it and she said what
she said all the women don't want to be
on the list
she said what's funny is all the women
don't want to be on the list and they
feel very uncomfortable with how much
they make and that anybody's going to
know it but every single man
argues that they should be higher on the
list
they're sitting in records about why
they should be jockeying for a higher
position i was like man
women can learn something from this you
don't need to be ashamed of your
success your success can be a light for
other people to go behind you so that's
the story i was trying to get to and we
ran out of time but she's amazing
you can get the book believe it and the
action plan at believeit.com it's just
incredible
uh how inspirational her story is what a
light she is
and i like how you just came for the
brothers on that one
[Laughter]
no ladies want to be humble guys we want
to be boastful guys sit down
no women need to stand up we got we both
got something to learn we both got
something to learn from that don't be
ashamed of what god's doing in your life
absolutely you don't need to apologize
for that so i thought that was cool
and that's a good one and for the guys
and whatever god is doing for your life
don't exaggerate it
you know yeah well you know one of the
things i see women and this is true with
business boutique but anything
we have all this is this is our posture
anthony's like oh
this little thing oh just this little i
just got this little side business oh
it's
nothing and i'm like you're diminishing
not only your own sense of
self-confidence but you're downplaying
playing the kindness and truth in
someone's compliments you're you're
apologizing for god's gifts in your life
like this is not humility
this is just not true and so i think
there's the confidence and humility are
not mutually exclusive
you can be confidently humble and you
know humbly confident and
and you can hold your life with open
hands so anyway i just love her example
because she is gracious and humble
and insanely successful and yes you can
be both and honestly
uh all jokes aside we need to hear
messages like hers
that's right you know to go from there
to now a billionaire a wealthy woman
um i mean we need that yeah and keep
your character intact along the way
she's so impressive absolutely
absolutely well let's get back to the
phone
uh christy triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're having a
conversation about your life your money
you wanna start a business the lady is
in the building if you are a woman and
you need encouragement in whatever area
of your life spiritually
mentally emotionally hey christy wright
is in the building
and for all y'all young people you want
to get this bag or you want to make some
money
for the older people over the generation
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five
and let's go out to new york and have a
conversation with matt matt good
afternoon how can
christy and i help good afternoon a
pleasure to talk to you guys uh
so i'm about to graduate from college uh
i have a job with secured with a 70 000
salary okay
and i'm going to graduate with a 30 000
event okay
so i already have eight thousand dollars
saved up and i want to like attack this
debt but uh the issue is
my my car that i currently use that i'm
gonna have to use
for my job uh it's uh kind of 20 years
old and uh
i suspect it's about to die in the next
year or so
so how do i like balance between like
making sure i have enough cash on hand
to like get a new car
or a new used car and uh attacking out
of debt
all right so you have eight thousand
dollars in a savings right
right okay cool and you're saying you
think
the car is going to die in a year right
yeah there's nothing like like
specifically wrong with it but this
thing just has been going wrong with it
uh
recently and uh yeah yeah i'm just
concerned about
longevity yeah i'll get you you ain't
concerned about the car because i think
i think you're concerned because you got
the money you want to go buy a newer car
um if nothing is going wrong with the
car right now this is what i want you to
do
i want you to take seven thousand
dollars of that and i want you to put it
towards your 30 000
of debt right now your student loans
then what i want you to do if you start
seeing issues with your car okay and it
starts
starts to have some issues i mean some
serious issues too matt
i'm not talking about you know you think
you heard something so now you need a
car now like no it's not working
it's broke it's not drivable then i have
no problem with you pausing paying off
this 30 000
but how old are you right now matt uh
i'm 21. yeah yeah yeah matt so
i want you to knock out this debt this
year
okay if you can be really get gazelle
focus
get intense get a purpose get driven um
you can pay off the debt
this year you're making seventy 000 on
there
how do you do something on the side to
generate another 20 000
this year so if you can pay off your
debt this year
then next year you can focus on saving
up cash to go buy you
a real nice quality used car so what i'm
going to say for you right now
is don't worry about um purchasing a new
car right now because you said nothing's
wrong with the car
right now great i would take it to the
shop maybe get it tuned up a little bit
you can take some of your eight thousand
dollars to do that
and get a good fresh get a good oil
change maybe some good new tires on
there
um then from there put the rest onto
your debt and just
just attack the debt then next year
let's go ahead and start the process
of saving yeah my my advice is so
similar to a call we had a little bit
earlier anthony that i would say
you're about to get this job where
you're making 75 000 a year
you need to pretend like you're not yes
you need to pretend like you're making
25 000 a year and because if not it's
gonna be oh my gosh this new big
exciting amount of money
oh i can live a little more comfortably
i can slow down on my debt snowball or
my student loans or
like anthony said need this car and
there is some you do need a car
at some point and so that's why you need
to stay serious live on way
less than you make have that margin to
take all that extra towards your student
loan towards the car whenever you need
it
and then after that you can get a little
bit more comfortable after you get your
savings up and all that kind of stuff
but i just don't want you to take your
foot off the gas because you've got
a lot more money than you're used to
having which will be easy to do so keep
that intensity even though you're making
more money now
absolutely matt and man and listen man
you're you're doing things right
yeah you're 21 years old making about 70
75 thousand dollars
you know the average income in america
right now is right around 48 to 54
000 depending on what part you're in so
you're ahead of the average person in
america
so now let's go ahead and get strategic
let's go ahead and think about what can
we do
to really set yourself up to be
successful down the road and that is pay
off all your debt
get a fully funded emergency fund and so
you do live in new york so
i know the prices up there are a little
bit more expensive so you're going to be
a little creative
but here's the main thing chris this is
what i tell everyone especially young
people
um you know when they're so young and
when they are ahead of the game a little
bit
get a clear why get a clear vision
and if you get a clearer why a clearer
vision then it's going to be very easy
for you to do the things that you have
to do to be successful
but if you don't have a clear why clear
vision then you'll have
those kind of questions well should i do
this should i do that but when you have
a clear why
there's a clear answer that you need to
take to get to your why not that but
that clear why is going to help you
avoid the
short temporary distractions of the bag
or whatever apparently i'm the old
people because you're like a bag or more
money i was like what does a bag mean i
guess i'm in the old
look all the young people are laughing
here oh my god i'm learning things from
ao today
learning things anyway that y will help
you resist those distractions and stay
focused
i forgot i am on the ramsey show i'm not
at the table with anthony o'neil i need
to
lord jesus i'm sorry y'all the bag means
money
i'm sorry james i'm sorry kelly i'm
sorry this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
have you ever wondered if an online
wheel is right for you do you need a
truss or a mirror wheel
what kind of power attorneys do you
actually need you hear me say
everyone needs a will and i seriously
mean this my cousin just passed away a
couple of weeks ago and she had a very
detailed will and life insurance in
place
and it was so peaceful for the family
but i get a lot of questions asking
if a simple online will is right for
someone specific situation
so with your question in mind our team
decided to build a quiz
that's right a quiz and this quiz gives
you custom results based on if you
you are married or single where you live
and
even the size of your estate it helps
you understand exactly what you need for
your specific situation so
i want you to take the quiz to find out
what you need to protect your family and
your wishes and you know what
your loved ones text word quiz
q-u-i-z-233789
will also text you back a promo code for
20
off your wheel so again text the word
quiz
q u i z 2 3 3
7 8 9 and i promise you
you will think uh me christy dave
our team later because i'm telling you
chris when we lost my cousin about
about actually about three weeks ago um
it was it was hard uh for our family
during that time and it still is hard
for us
but to to see that she had her will in
place
and to see that she had her life
insurance in place and to see that she
had the correct powers of attorney in
place as well which we couldn't use the
power's attorney then but
she had the right people on the account
to get to it we were able to mourn with
peace
not more with stress yeah i think
probably the number one reason i would
guess that people
don't do it is because they just don't
want to face it they don't want to think
about it they never get around to it
it's not fun i understand that
but gosh the peace of mind once you do
it and we've made it so easy on people
to be able to do this
the peace of mind you have knowing that
that's all okay like i i had surgery in
november and of course leading up to
surgery
um i just want to make sure everything's
in place yeah just in case anything
wrong
you know and it's like oh dave we've got
everything in place and so it's just
it's just gives you the peace of mind
and also gives your family the peace of
mind so it's just great advice
oh man all right text word quiz quiz to
33789
and your family will be very grateful
because when you have that stuff in mind
what you're telling your family is i
love you
you know that's what you're saying i
love you and thank you and i'll see you
soon
uh let's go out to indianapolis and talk
to luke
luke good afternoon uh how can uh
christy and i help
hey good afternoon to both of you as
always thank you for
the help you provide yeah yeah what's
going on so yeah so at my church i i
lead a group and
we're actually going through fpu and uh
this past weekend we're talking about
baby step three
three to six weeks and actually tomorrow
three to six months and tomorrow
uh we will be debt free tomorrow we're
paying off revenue
my big question my wife and i uh other
people in the group have the same
question
three versus six months so we played the
clip in the video you know based on
a single family a single income family
or how reliable commission based
so if i can give you my circumstances i
i'd really appreciate you helping me out
three versus six months
yeah yeah yeah um so i'm retired
military 20 years so i have
retirement day that's never going to go
away um i have disability from the
military that's not going to go away
okay and i'm a school teacher
okay school teacher pay of course can go
away my wife she uh we homeschool we
have seven
daughters seven yeah and i'm watching
them play out the window right now it's
amazing a lot of estrogen
yeah and and so um
while we are a single family income i am
the sole person
at the same time the military and the
disability comes out to about
46 000 a year and my pay
for being a teacher is about 45 000. so
it's kind of funny i get paid more for
doing nothing now than i get paid for
teaching
but uh you know but we have seven kids
so
even though some of the income is
reliable you know more kids you you have
more
events could happen that you need to dig
in more expensive that emergency
but the sooner that we can get past baby
step three i mean baby says four five
and six i've got a lot of colleges to
start saving up for for these kids yeah
yeah
so i i don't want to put a lot of cash
in savings or
a money market that's i don't need to
yeah yeah so i'm looking for advice
yeah yeah so luke what's your uh
guaranteed annual income right now
uh if i were to quit or get fired from
teaching my guaranteed income from the
military and
uh disability is 45 46 000. but there's
no there's no indication that
anything's wrong with the teaching right
like that's been stable up to this point
that's a hypothetical
i just want to clarify this not only is
the hypothetical i finished my grad
degree in educational leadership i'm
i'm thinking about being a principal
that which would of course come with the
pay raise yeah so that's that's
as far as we know that's a steady stable
job yes yeah okay so if you're going to
combine everything then um
we're looking at 92 or 93 000. yeah
yeah 92 000 yeah so you're good
with no debt um you're perfectly fine
with just three months
yeah i would i'll just jump into the
reason we give people a range
even when you're talking about finances
that is mathematical and formula based
and there are
steps and principles there's always
going to be a range and comfort level
there are going to be some people that
they will not sleep at night unless they
have six months
just because that's their comfort level
even if all the numbers add up fine and
there's other people that are like
i feel pretty good with three months i
want to go ahead and get that money
going into college fund so
the range is really for you to customize
that aspect of it to
your comfort level and so if you and
your wife and have a conversation you
feel good about your steady income and
you feel good at three months and
or three months worth of expenses and
you want to start to put that money
towards colleges because it's a very
valid
reason to want to go ahead and do that i
think that's totally fine i think
there's just a little bit of room for
customization within that range
absolutely i mean i i totally agree with
christy we want you to choose
um now if you would have called in and
say hey i'm on a commission-based job i
don't have any savings i still have debt
which way you don't have debit until you
pay off all your debt but if you didn't
have something stable and situated
then yeah we may say hey you know go
ahead and get six months because
uh you're not as stable with your income
but with you you're stable
luke you have good some good income
you're out of debt
yes set aside three months and going
ahead and jump over to babe steps four
uh through six right now so i would
definitely do that
but thank you so much for for uh doing
the class and
and i before you go like i'm curious uh
throughout your debt-free journey what
was the hardest part of your journey
so i was actually going to say that for
everyone that's listening and hasn't
taken the plunge
um starting that one thousand dollars
there is a mental
leap that you have to take it's a mental
game and if you're not willing to take
that you're not all in
and you just go ish well just don't do
it yeah wait till next year when you're
ready
so making that first leap and saying
we're in it to win it
um and not going ish the commit the
first the first step
the first step that's right yeah that's
good man good advice good advice for
money or anything
just commit you know what uh uh i think
it's seth godin has a great quote he
says if you wait until you have success
to commit you'll have neither you need
to commit to this thing
whether it's the baby steps or your
business or
whatever you need to commit and then
you'll have success you will not have
success if you halfway tiptoe ish your
way through you'll never have either so
let's stay right there chrissy
let's turn on christy's teaching head um
what if someone said okay i want to
commit i know i need to do this but like
what are the first let's say
two things that they need to do to
actually commit
to the process to the journey so you
know one of the things we talk a lot
around here
is action i tell people all the time
it's not the thought that counts
i don't know who came up with that no
one cares what you thought about doing
no one's bragging about what your
husband thought about getting you for
your anniversary
no one's posting on facebook about what
your kids thought about earning on their
report cards
it's what you do that counts but what's
interesting is
if you take a tiny baby step literally a
baby step in anything not just financial
baby steps
but that's why we broke it down this way
if you take a tiny baby step
it builds your confidence and it fuels
your momentum
to take the second tiny baby step and
the thirty third tiny baby step and so
on you look up one day
and you've built the business you've
lost the way you've gotten out of debt
you've done the thing
but it didn't happen overnight it
happened one tiny baby step at a time
but it all
started with taking a step it's that
step that moves it's the first domino
yes then the second is easier the third
is easier you start to get some
adrenaline some endorphins some reward
from your hard work some payoff you cut
off
cut up the credit card you lose the
weight you whatever that thing is you
get your first sale you're like oh my
gosh i'm doing this yes
research shows anthony that the most
motivating thing
to people male female any age does not
matter
the most motivating thing to human
beings from a psychological perspective
is not
money it's not rewards it's not uh
recognition
it's seeing progress seeing the scale to
go down seeing the bank account go up
you see progress you want to do more of
that so make some progress
i told you she a teacher y'all chris c
wright ladies and gentlemen
yes yes yes oh man this has been a great
hour thank you chrissy thank you james
thank you kelly
hey you guys we'll be right back this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
do
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money my name is anthony
o'neill host of the popular youtube and
podcast show
the table with anthony o'neil and
co-hosting with me is number one
national bestselling author
and also host of the very popular the
christy wright show
that you can see on youtube and on
podcasts
and so we're here to take your phone
calls about anything if you're a lady
want to start a business give christy
right a call if you're a lady you want
to
figure out how to go after your dreams
and your purpose give
christy a call uh you want to learn i
was about to say something i was about
to say something i was about to say it
again christie
if you want to get a bag no no no no no
if you want if you want to make some
money if you want to learn how to get
your money right uh and for the
the hip hop culture if you want to learn
how to secure a bag
give us a call at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
uh triple eight eight two five five two
two five and you can hit chrissy or
myself up on social media
at christy christie b wright um and
anthony at anthony o'neill
let's go out to uh phoenix christy and
talk to uh barbara
good afternoon barbara how can christy
and i help hi
um i have an invention and i'm trying to
figure out the steps i need to
take to make that happen and protect
myself
oh what's your invention barbara are we
allowed to know or is it a secret
you well i'm not gonna say exactly it's
a cleaner product i have a cleaning
service
okay so it's something that i've looked
at
doing because i've used different things
you know to
to do this and um so i have something i
think will work
better than what anybody else has cool
that's awesome
so when you say you have this i'm
guessing you already have a
prototype or a sample that you created
on your own
or you need to get that made well yes
and yes
um i have part of it and i need to
make a uh it'll require a handle so i
need to i have an idea in my head of how
i want the handle to be
because of how i want the product to
work but
i i don't know do i go to an engineer do
i go to a lawyer first do i
what do i do because i don't want
somebody to be able to steal
my idea you know i know i'm going to
have to have a patent on it
yeah yeah yeah well i would say i would
say this
when you are kind of uh just in those
first
early stages of exploring and research
research and development you're kind of
getting prototypes you're asking
questions you're refining your idea
i genuinely would not worry about
someone stealing it because you're so
under the radar you're not posting this
all over the world
you're not broadcasting it you're just
discreetly going to some different
vendors
uh seeing who you know whether it's a
company a manufacturing company that
makes a
prototype a mold you know plastic molds
you got to look into some of the cost
and what's the most efficient way to do
it
i would encourage you to find the
um simplest smallest way to start
because if when you're looking at molds
for example if it's a plastic
based uh handle that you know whatever
your design is that can get really
pricey in terms of upfront costs and i
don't want you to do that until you
prove the concept and get some sales in
but what you can do is you can just
start to dig around a little bit i would
say that
look in your area in phoenix first
search
locally because there's something so
invaluable to going in person
to the manufacturing plant to shaking
hands with the people that are running
it to seeing what their options are how
they work behind the scenes behind the
curtain
versus dealing with an online vendor
you're gonna have a lot more options
online but gosh you just could also make
some mistakes and lose some money
in translation even if you did pick
someone online i would i would go travel
to where they're located to see
where that where and how they want to
look for a company that manufactures
handles yeah that's what you're looking
for the other thing i would i would
do some digging is and this is uh this
is a very
common best practice in business don't
feel like you're doing anything shady
you can ask other companies that are
doing something similar that are
manufacturing their own similar products
maybe it's not a
cleaning handle but it's a different
type of handle or maybe it's a different
type of product in a different industry
and just say hey how'd you do this who'd
you talk to do you know of anybody
just ask around and that is a perfectly
normal thing to do in business a lot of
people will be willing to share
resources contacts
company names hey i've got a guy over
here he may not be the guy but he's got
someone over here
whatever the thing is you're just going
to do some scrappy digging
research and i would say that even when
you find an
option to manufacture your handle
you want to get three different samples
from three different vendors you want to
get three different quotes compare costs
compare commitment
um and that type of thing before you
make your decision and then and only
then barbara once you have got it locked
in you're like i want to go with this
company
here's how many we're going to
manufacture here's how much it's going
to cost here's what all the logistics of
fulfillment is
once you do that then i would get
serious before you maybe sign with them
then i would get serious about a patent
and and you don't need a patent attorney
you can go to uspto.gov
that's united states patent and
trademark office.gov
and you can file for a patent yourself
it's a little it's a little bit of you
know maybe two thousand dollars you can
do it yourself you don't need to pay all
the thousands of dollars and attorneys
fees to do that for you so you do that
then but first let's figure out your
idea and concept and then you're ready
to do the paperwork side of it but
that's awesome i
think that's i think that's really cool
and i think you should do it i can't
wait to hear how it goes
that's really cool wow listen that's why
i said give us a call we got we got the
she's the one right there tell her how
to do it tell her how to save some money
still pursue her dreams but here's
here's the first steps yeah that's why
you need to
be intimidating when you have an idea
because you're like well i've got this
awesome idea how do i bring it
bring it into action those first steps
can be a little a little intimidating
but you can do it
absolutely absolutely uh max is in
philadelphia uh good afternoon man how
can uh christy and i help
hey thank you so much for taking that
call really appreciate it yeah go ahead
real quick we got about two minutes so
uh good to your question so um yeah i'm
on baby step two
um i am trying to figure out ways to
increase my
shovel to fill this mess that i've made
in um i just uh
so i got a 5k increase for a new
position at work
within the last couple weeks and i just
found out that i got a little over 5000
bonus for the year okay um i have a
pretty unique ability to play piano and
sing on the side
okay and i'm wondering whether it's
acceptable to sort of put
some money into that whether it's you
know i've been thinking about getting
this piano shell that sort of mimics a
grand piano
to throw that tip chart kind of right in
people's faces uh for
those kind of request songs or you know
i'm kind of feeling guilty about even
the idea of putting a pause in the baby
baby steps i also have to get into some
sort of car to be able to get to those
gigs
which i don't have right now how much
debt do you have right now uh max
uh so i have 13 in about so it's
an old car loan uh that isn't around
anymore due to an
accident so i should be getting some
settlement money at some point
okay i i have no idea when though but uh
and then yeah
like two hundred thousand dollars in
student loans yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'll tell you real quick max you
don't need to put any money from your
bonus into your side gig if you're in a
different type of business like you're a
fitness coach and you don't have
equipment to do what you need to do i'd
say yeah
you don't need it for what you do you're
able to do what you do on the side
without taking any money just get a
bigger tip jar
from like walmart and just stick it in
their face on top of the piano the
things that
i'm hearing don't sound necessary they
sound nice but not necessary
so put that money on your on your debt
don't worry about you don't need that to
do what you do
yeah man i agree i totally agree with
chrissy
there's no need to spend any extra money
or anything you need to put all the
money
uh towards your debt because you need
financial freedom you don't need
anything extra for your business now i
do want you to consider keep that side
gig
so you can keep some money generating
people towards your debt
but don't spend any more money into that
all right
get out of debt keep the bag this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsey to find out more
[Music]
monique is in san antonio texas with
a great question uh for christy monique
how can
christina help hi y'all it's an honor to
be on your show i've been listening to
dave and everyone for years
um i have a question for christy i have
read ken coleman's proximity principle
and i just started your book christy
business boutique
awesome and um i'm just at the beginning
and kind of
i feel like god's been slapping in my
face i've prayed about it i've lived the
corporate life forever
and i know there's so much more out
there for me i have a chronic illness i
do live with multiple sclerosis i've had
it for about seven years or so
and i want to share with not just other
people
with multiple sclerosis but anybody with
a chronic illness the importance of
health and fitness
and a positive attitude i think goes a
long way too
because i'm open about it but there's
people that don't know and when people
find out i have this they're like i
would have never guessed that monique
and
how do you do it because i know somebody
that has it and they don't do this kind
of
such a bad attitude i don't want to do
anything so i've
i want to start a blog well i have my
website already i purchased that
i don't know and i want to go into
fitness training for people with
disabilities and i just i don't know if
this is something that could potentially
become a career
or even how to start i've seen all these
like on facebook and everywhere oh
pay x amount of hundred dollars and
we'll teach you how to blog and earn
money
and i just don't know if this is
something solely because i've seen
in your book you've said it all you need
is social media and you can start a
whole new career i guess i'm still kind
of how do i go about doing this and is
this
a idea that maybe could go somewhere
um it's kind of what i'm reaching out to
you for christy
yeah absolutely well first let me ask
you a really basic question
do you like to write i do and i love
telling my story because i want to help
people
because i feel like there's so much that
people don't know about the illness and
what's available to them out there
from everything to assistance with drugs
and do you need these certain
medications or not
yeah i feel like there's so much i've
learned in my time and um
the power of a positive attitude and how
to help people so
that's where i'm at and i do love to
talk and write about it
okay well here the reason i asked is
because you definitely have a message
and you definitely have people you want
to help with it so that is clear
where i want to challenge you a little
bit is blogging isn't your only way to
do that
here's what i hear and i'm just and
you're just on the phone with me monique
i hear such
expressiveness in your voice that i
would be willing to bet you'd be good on
camera
you would be good on a podcast you would
be good on a youtube channel now i'm not
saying you have to do that but the
reason i'm challenging you there is
making money through blogging is very
similar to making money through
podcasting or youtubing so you really
get to pick what is your medium to share
your message
and maybe you do multiple ones i do
multiple ones but you want to start with
one
you want to start with one and get good
at it to get your message out what's
cool is
when you start to help people through
that medium then you're going to learn
what messages are resonating what
information people need and you can
always add branches on to
how you do that now here's the deal
making money through blogging
or youtube or podcasting or anything
like that is
a slow process if you don't have a
product product or service to sell
you're selling advertising or
sponsorships or affiliate marketing
you've got to have eyeballs
ears clicks to be able to monetize it if
you're talking about
just monetizing the blog itself or the
podcast itself
a better way to approach it is i'm going
to look at this as a marketing channel
for anthony and i we don't make very
much money for our company or ourselves
through our podcast
show where the money comes in is the
back end when we talk about oh by the
way i have a devotional living true 40
days get back to you or i have a book
business boutique or anthony has a book
debt-free degree
when we talk about these additional
resources that people buy
that's where the revenue stream is but
the the podcast the show
the blog that's the it's more of a
marketing megaphone
as an example so you can approach it
either way you can do both you can have
affiliates and sponsorships and we have
that as well
but that's not going to be the bulk of
your revenue unless you just have a
massive following which when you're
starting you don't so
right what i want to challenge you to do
as a starting point is
think about which sounds the most fun to
you being on camera through youtube
being on a podcast or writing and you
like i said you can always add them in
later but man
if people are saying to you monique i
never would have known
that you struggle with this then
visually they see
something in you that inspires them
and i don't think that comes through in
a blog i just want to challenge you
there
you're going to be able to possibly
amaze people inspire people help people
more when they
see your presentation on camera or hear
the expressiveness in your voice on a
podcast and they go oh my gosh she
struggles with ms i would never would
have known
and and make that much more of an impact
so i just want to challenge you there
you there's no right or wrong you do
what's right for you
but then begin to think about what's the
revenue stream
um in addition to is it a course is it
coaching
is it um you know some other type of
consulting is there some
other uh back-end revenue stream that's
going to make it more profitable
for you faster than just waiting on
eyeballs to come
and monetizing those to advertisers so i
just want you to think about that the
revenue side
but also think of the medium but i
definitely think you should do it when
you start to dip your toe in
you'll start to learn more about what
you like and what works and you want to
do more of that
great question wow that was an amazing
question this is fine this is this is i
love it i love it man let's keep the
conversation going
let's go out to cincinnati have a
conversation here with uh allison
good afternoon allison how can christy
and i help
hi are you there i'm yes what's up okay
um so my husband and i are trying to
decide
we're in baby step 3b
okay um and saving for a house what our
monthly payment should be
because we make about 8 000 a month
okay so that would be the 25 for 2000
however
we have a one-year-old and a
three-year-old in full-time daycare
and that's a pretty steep cost it's
about 20 a month
okay so should we subtract that from the
8 000
to come up with the monthly mortgage
payment
i mean i think for you at this present
time now do you you have no debt right
correct okay and you have a fully funded
emergency fund correct
yeah all right i just want to make sure
that we're super clear on that um so i
think for me
the bear max not the bear max but the
max
you can go to is two thousand dollars
that's going to be 25
of your take home pay and so if you want
to go down lower
than 2 000 by all means do that if you
feel as if you will be a little bit more
it will it will be a little bit more
comfortable for you and your family uh
but i firmly believe that two thousand
dollars is a great mortgage
right uh but then at the same time how
can we maybe cut out on some other some
other expenses
so that we can live in a comfortable
house but if you want to go down to 1500
a month totally great it goes back to
what we were talking about earlier
anthony where it's like there's a
there's a comfort level that you get to
have the discernment to decide what are
we comfortable with i'll tell you for
matt and i
as we have made more money over the last
10 years we have not upgraded
our home and lifestyle we will at some
point but we haven't and so we have more
margin
yes and that margin is peace of mind
when my son went in the hospital a few
years ago
peace of mind there's no even with an
emergency peace of mind
and so i will say that allison if you're
even a little bit concerned about
you don't have to go up to the limit
that's a rule of thumb absolutely you
can buy
a home that's a little bit less than
that still meets what you want in a home
but you don't have to max it out just
because you quote-unquote can because
it's the formula
again use your discernment and your
comfort level and if you know like hey
i'd feel better having a little bit more
margin and wiggle room with two young
kids which are highly unpredictable then
by all means feel free to do that i
think you need to do what's right for
you
absolutely i mean absolutely what is
your husband i think allison
um we go back and forth every day
yeah yeah i definitely i i definitely
don't i definitely agree with with
chrissy just sit down with your husband
and you all figure out what's
comfortable for you just don't go above
two thousand dollars
but if you're saying hey let's just
stick around 1250 a month hey that is
that is great
i mean we we want you to be comfortable
uh we don't want you living paycheck to
paycheck
we want you to have freedom we want you
to have peace um
but then at the same time i'm not just
looking at my mortgage payment too
chrissy i'm looking at everything though
you know where can i cut out on some
things
where can i cut off on daycare a little
bit where can i find maybe
i want to say a cheaper daycare but like
a daycare that may be still good
but even is within my budget yeah and
the other thing that's so
interesting too about margin especially
when you're in this baby step and this
is kind of what you're working towards
if you're able to be in a home you like
and have that margin then when things
come up you cash flow
easier you're not having to save for 10
months for an expense it comes quicker
because man you've got so much margin to
put at it it just it makes a big
difference
it really does it really does well y'all
i'm excited because coming up next on
the next segment
we got two young people on the debt-free
stage
that's right so you all definitely want
to come back after this tell your mama
tell your daddy
get the cats get the dogs cause we bout
to have a debt free screen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christy america i'm excited
because we have in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage two
young people
james and megan megan see i'm getting
excited can't
say a name right man i get excited you
know uh when i see two young people on
the stage
um who are clearly debt free so
give us the information how much debt
did you pay off
we paid off 93 000 in
about 25 months 93 000
in 25 months yes y'all was working and
then how much
was your combined household income
during that time where did you start
where did you finish
well for the first six months we're at
about forty three thousand dollars
what then we went up to yeah
i'm trying to do the math here okay and
we went up to about a hundred thirty
thousand dollars
a hundred and thirty then that's chris
that's how you secure the bag
right here on the stage his bag went big
so what okay so what happened uh
from for you ought to go from 43 000 to
hundred and thirty thousand dollars
income yeah
yeah so we got out of college and had
student loan debt and all those things
and so
we um he was finishing up the police
academy um and i was working
and then it took a little while to find
a job so
when he finally found a job we were able
to keep living like we were
living on one income in order to make
sure that we were paying off our debt
smart yeah what what do you all two do
i'm a police officer
and megan's a teacher amazing two
amazing careers that's right
thank you both serving our country
that's right yes yes
all right so i'm assuming the 93 000 is
in student loans
majority of them well it was about 60
000
in student loans okay i had the majority
of that
um all right uh two car notes
and just a couple other miscellaneous
like three thousand oh so y'all thousand
dollars in credit card debt
absolutely normal that's it
student loans two nice cars and some you
know some other small stuff okay cool so
um what happened you know what made you
all want to attack this 93 000
in student loans well i didn't think we
had a problem at all we're just living
day to
um and i got an invite we got to invite
to
attend my high school football coach
and his wife for dinner we met them for
dinner
and they were just happy they were
excited they were like hey we gotta tell
you about this thing we pay we're paying
off our debt like we're getting out of
it and
just to see their faces light up and for
them to tell us i was like megan we we
have to do something
but before that um right after we got
married someone actually gave us
dave ramsey's total money makeover book
okay with a hundred dollars
so we took the hundred dollars and we
kind of tossed the book aside like
you know we don't need that everybody
does every wedding gift ever
so after dan and carolyn uh invited us
over for dinner
we went back scrambling looking for the
book and we couldn't find it
we don't know who gave it to us either
so yeah so shout out to whoever gave us
that book for
our wedding gift but we read the book
and like i just lit up i read the book
in
a couple hours actually i just sat down
and read the whole thing and
megan was on board and
wait wait yeah wait you read the whole
book in a couple of hours like in one
two hours
it was like it was like six hours oh
yeah no
not a couple but like six hours yeah
still reading the book in six hours but
it takes me six weeks
it usually does too but that book i just
couldn't put down for some reason
i was determined i was definitely
determined yeah that is cool
that is awesome so i'm curious when you
decided to make this commitment what was
the first like
few weeks like when you realized like
okay we've decided
and now you gotta make some sacrifices
and actually take action on it that for
some people between idea to action is
hard talk about that kind of
that stage right there yeah yeah we our
budget was really jacked up the first
time
everybody says yeah we never sat down
and budgeted anything we didn't know
where our money was going or what was
happening so
it was just a mess yeah after that after
we finally
kind of configured what we wanted to
budget for everything it got easier but
it took some hard conversations letting
go of certain things and just
making sure that we were doing what we
needed to do to get where we wanted to
go
so what would you two say is the key to
getting out of debt what's that
one key uh to the millions of people
listening to your message right now um
it definitely takes commitment um with
anything i
never went through a process before
where i mean
i was that committed for that long too
i mean two years it was seemed like a
long time
it was it was a long journey but looking
back at it it went by quick to us
um but definitely commitment in if i can
add a one
b it would be budgeting for sure could
it be
yeah budgeting was was great yeah
that's so good um i'm gonna put you on
the spot
what's your why like why did you all
really really want to become debt free
uh think about 10 years down the road
like why does this matter to you two as
a married couple young married couple
well i'll kind of talk about my why i
don't know um i was going through the
police academy i wasn't making any
income
and megan was taking care of the entire
family and we had a
two-month-old son at home wow so um he
he's definitely our why my why
of why we did things i mean i don't want
him to go through the process we had
with student
loans and other debt so because we took
the
sacrifice a short sacrifice to pay off
our debt he would never have to
experience that again
so just knowing that i mean that's
amazing for me that's awesome
megan yeah i think mine was really
motivated by micah he
we had to struggle through and make sure
that our
our loans are paid off but we don't want
him to have to go through that
um and just not have to worry about
money in general yeah
that's so good who was y'all's two
biggest cheerleaders
we actually had a couple um her
sister alyssa and her husband alex they
went through financial peace
university with us they actually are
debt free as well that's great
um and dan and carolyn the couple that
introduce us to the dave ramsey playing
so shout out to them shout out to him
so how does it feel i mean how let me
ask this question if you don't want to
answer it
um i totally understand but how old are
you two i'm 26 and megan will be 26 next
[Laughter]
you're week to get fired up i know that
face i know that face you get excited
you're 26 years old paid off 93 000
in two years in one month
i just got to ask how does it feel to be
on the
end of the millennial age you know and
you're debt free you have a beautiful
son
like how does it feel it feels amazing
it really does i i i didn't know it was
gonna feel this great until
it hit us i mean i thought the entire
plan was a scam
i want to be honest with you then uh i
mean we just saw
we just started tackling in debt our
debt and we're like we can do this we
really can
i mean it feels amazing wow and it feels
amazing to not have to work all the
overtime that works
so just take a break and i mean it feels
it feels amazing it does
your hard work has paid off that's
amazing listen man
oh man i'm this is the ramsay show so i
gotta be i gotta be careful what i say
because i'm just excited for you too
you know when i see young people like
yourself focused determined
living with intentionality saying hey we
want to be debt-free so our son
can enjoy life grow up without debt and
then pass that on to
his kids and to their kids it started
with you all that's right
you two are the legacy beginners man i
just i just salute you man so clearly
you two are on your way to becoming
everyday millionaires so we have a copy
of uh our good friend chris hogan's book
everyday millionaires for you
man this this is amazing is micah here
he is
let's get him out let's get michael on
the stage you guys
man james and megan paid off 93
000 in 25 months making 43
130 thousand dollars in a year
let's hear a debt free scream counted
down
you guys three three two one
[Music]
wow i mean chris
i mean at 26 you're older than me right
christy
okay we don't need to bring that up a uh
we don't
okay he feels a little pointed anybody
i'm just saying crazy well i'm just
saying
at 26 were you thinking like that no i
was hit i was
realizing i had to turn something around
that was the beginning of my journey not
the end of it
for sure that for sure that's awesome
and christie is older than me hey
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five
five two two five this is the ramsay
show
and sitting in today is christy wright
number one national best-selling author
and anthony o'neil and
i've written a book once or twice
but man we are here to take your phone
calls and to really have a great time
we love laughing we love just talking
and helping and serving people
and so we're going to keep it going on
the phone lines uh chrissy let's have a
conversation with alex out in tampa
florida good afternoon alex how can
christy and i hey y'all how's it going
here
uh long time less than our first time
caller over here all right
how can we help i got a question for
y'all
uh we are a first time home buyer and uh
the real estate market down here in
florida is hot and i just like it
everywhere everywhere else in the us
okay and i just wanted to get your
opinion on that's a
first-time home buyer here and um if we
should
still continue the rent or if we should
go ahead and pull the trigger
and buy or build right now
um or wait till the summer or wait till
you know no one can time the market but
i was just curious on what your all
thoughts were on that since this is the
highest the market's ever been
with the with the lowest inventory cool
great great great give me a little bit
about yourself you know how much are you
out of debt
uh yeah yeah we are completely out of
debt it's gonna be uh
my fiance uh courtney and i okay uh
we uh we have about 180 uh saved up
we're completely out of debt
okay 100 um is that 180k on top of your
savings or is that total 180 000
uh that's a total of 180 000 saved
between the
two of us that's amazing that's real i
mean you you two are killing the game
all right
so yeah um so i like that so do you two
plan on staying
in florida once you two get married uh
yeah so we're getting married here in a
few months
and uh we'll be uh we'll be the
uh in the tampa area looking for a uh
home
cool great well here's my suggestion you
clearly have the money
okay um i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
spend 180
thousand dollars to put down on a home
i'm going to look at what what will it
take to have at least three to six
months of your emergencies inside of
there if you two have a stable income a
stable job
uh then i would definitely go ahead and
just keep it down to maybe uh just three
months
uh but if you're liking freelance um
entrepreneurship type stuff i would go
ahead and set aside six months
and so you'll have at least a hundred
thousand dollars put into a home so
generally what what what we tend to say
is
um wait one year after you get married
so you and your wife together can go
around looking and see what
you know what you all like get used to
living with each other and i still like
that
for you too even though you all are
already in tampa and you're going to
stay in tampa
but i do believe that you should go in
ahead and just maybe save up a little
bit more
and just spend at least give yourself
six months in the same house
learning each other learning what you
like learning okay
we need this now since we understand how
to
live with each other uh so i would
suggest
uh when are y'all getting married alex
yeah we're getting married in
september oh congratulations well it's
interesting too because what's so cool
about your position
um financially especially is you have
options
so if something happened to come on the
market that's just the most perfect
house in the whole world and you prayed
about it and you feel like god is this
is the thing
then you're in a position to buy it if
you wanted to but i could not agree with
anthony moore because i will tell you
totally transparent and this is not
talking behind
matt's back but matt and i would both
agree the first marriage first year of
marriage was hard
everyone talks about the newlywed phase
and it is fun but you are bringing your
own set of expectations to even just
living in a house with someone of how
they grew up and you grew up and who's
doing what dishes and chores
and and so what's so cool is if you add
the extra stress of
buying a home decorating a home uh
owning a home and all the maintenance
that goes into that on top of that first
year
it will add to your stress now it's not
that you can't do it
but i agree with anthony i think if you
babystep that and you said okay first
step
let's just get used to living together
as newlyweds with less pressure and the
landlord can take care of the
maintenance
second step let's buy a home and and
take on that new level of challenge
together
i think it's just going to spread it out
make it a little bit more enjoyable for
you
it's not like you have to but man i
think that's the maybe the smarter
option yeah great question alex and
congrats
on yeah congratulations your wife doing
that hey stay on the line since you two
are getting married i'm gonna have kelly
give you
a free year subscription to um ramsay
plus
and so cuz you all are gonna be starting
off in baby steps four through six
and so i definitely would love to uh
just so into y'all's marriage
because i i'm praying that it's gonna be
fruitful and
you all will be married for years and
years and years and years and years
until both of you all go home to see the
lord so that's along forever
hey blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer for custom window
covering you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run
every month you'll save even more use
promo code ramsey to get the best deal
rules and restrictions apply today's
question comes from dialin
in new york um i've been a part i've
been a part-time
freelance proofreader for a little over
two years now
i'm ready to expand my business but
there are only so many hours in a day
christy
i currently turn down about two projects
a month because i don't have
time to do them i'm thinking about
subcontracting
out the projects i don't have time for
but i'm not sure how i would structure
their pay
or if it's morally okay to accept work
from a client
and then give it to someone else to do
though i would review every job to make
sure it's highly
quality high quality what do you think
christie
two things super simple number one raise
your prices
period raise your prices if the demand
is higher than the supply
the supply being the hours you have in a
day it is time to raise your prices
and then that is just that's showing you
what you're able to do at this time it's
a great time to raise your prices
second thing is when you talk about is
it morally okay to accept work from a
client and then give it to someone else
do
that is what business is when you employ
team members so of course it's morally
okay the only thing that you might want
to do just for your own peace of mind
and to be fully up front with the client
is to let them know that your
subcontractor your team member however
you want to
uh phrase it and structure that that
person's employment with you
uh you should be upfront that they're
going to do it and you let them know
like hey i'm going to pass this off to
so and so they're going to but i'm going
to supervise it i'm going to make sure
the quality of work when it comes to
that
you need to think through the pay so
you're going to build in
to the the cost for the client the
amount that you're going to pay the
subcontractor the team member to do it
and the amount of money that you're
gonna make off the top for running the
business because you're running a
business now and you're employing people
so you can do either
you can raise your prices or subcontract
it out
and manage that like a business um or
you can do both
and uh all of them are good ideas and
that's exactly what you should be doing
when your business is expanding and the
demand is growing great question oh man
that's such a
real good question um you know it's so
funny because
when you was answering the question
christy i was like absolutely man people
do this every single day all the time
all the time every single day yeah
that's right i call one company yeah
we're going to send out a contractor but
i called you
well they work for us that's right so
there's there's nothing wrong with it
just make sure that whoever's
representing you
um is doing a great job at what they're
doing so this is what's your brand
on it your name on it your reputation
absolutely hey you guys are you feeling
um stuck with your money uh like you've
never
you'll never get out of debt or save
enough uh for the future listen
it doesn't have to be that way and you
can make progress with your money
and faster than you think but the only
way to make it happen
is with a budget again we just heard the
debt free couple say
you got to get on the b word a budget
that's why you need
ramsey plus membership you'll get access
to the premium version of our every
dollar budgeting app
you'll be able to plan out every dollar
you'll spend
and save before the month begins connect
your budget to your bank so you can
never miss any transactions and get
custom budget reports that shows you
where you can find
more money and put towards your goals
when you budget and get intentional with
your money
you will make progress let me say that
one more time
when you budget when you have a vision
for your money
and get intentional with your money
you will make progress and progress very
fast
and you can start budgeting for free
today
to start your free trial of ramsay plus
go to daveramsey.com
that's daveramsey.com
i can't tell you how much i love
budgeting
i didn't like it at first chris it would
be real really oh i didn't like it
i didn't like it because i i was able to
see where i was spending the majority of
my money and i didn't like
looking at myself see i like i'm the
control freak i like the control like oh
i get to just move these numbers around
and control it and see it
and it's like a game i love it i'm glad
that you loved it i didn't like it
but now i do love it well that's a wrap
for this hour man it's been fun
christy james kelly america thank you so
much
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money my name is
anthony o'neill host of the
popular youtube and podcast show the
table with anthony o'neil
and co-hosting with me today is number
one national best-selling author christy
wright and host
of the christy wright show and author of
the most recent
book um living true yeah
i'm so excited about that christy this
book is fire so this is so fun because
did you know i don't know if you knew
this ao
okay this is the very first devotional
our company's ever put out
you know i just love to get away with
stuff and try i just i love to push the
boundaries a little bit
i see you listen a couple years ago i
just really
felt a desire and a call to write a
devotional and here's the thing
this is something i have felt and this
is something i've heard from for over a
decade
of working with women i remember
speaking at one of my first speaking
events at purdue university in 2010
and a woman walked up to me after i
spoke on life balance and she said
i just feel like i've lost myself wow
and i've heard those words
and it's not just women but i think
women uniquely experience that whether
it's in motherhood different seasons of
life
different jobs or careers you feel like
you lose yourself in your own life and
you're going where
am i wow in my own life and so i really
felt like god was calling me to
tackle this topic so we released it just
a couple months ago it's called living
true
40 days to get back to you and what's
cool about 40 days and you know this
because you're a church guy but 40 is a
very biblical number now
and it's also not intimidating for a
busy
woman that wants to read it because even
even not just 365 days but 100 days
that's
that's a big commitment for someone
who's super busy but 40 days
to get back to you and i walk through
four sections who god is
who you are where you are in your season
of life and where you're going and what
god says about each of those we spend 10
days
on each of them and ao it's been really
cool and you know this when you put
something new out in the world
you're excited about it but it feels a
little bit vulnerable and you're like i
don't know is this going to connect is
this going to do what i want it to do
and it is just blowing up in terms of
reviews and and the the stories of
people spending time with god or god
speaking to them on just what they need
to hear on just that day which by the
way
is what god does that's not what
christie wrote does that's what god does
and the holy spirit but it has been cool
to see how god is using that
to help women get back to themselves and
get back to who they were created to be
man listen listen you guys i need you to
get this book um and
for the brothers get the book for your
wife oh mother's day's coming up oh
mother's day is coming up you know get
the book for your mother get the book
for your wife get the book for your
girlfriends and you know i want you to
live true
you know what i was thinking about doing
so 40 40 is such a biblical number with
the
40 days it rained 40 days jesus was
tempted in the wilderness you know
another 40 days
between the resurrection and the
ascension so i think i'm going to start
on monday
april 5th the day after easter and i
think i'm going to walk through this on
instagram
with people for those 40 days when jesus
appears i mean i know it's symbolic
because it's easter but
wouldn't that be cool i think i'm gonna
do that absolutely if you follow me on
instagram
christy b wright we're gonna walk
through that so get your copy so you can
join us for those 40 days
go to chrissyright.com you guys go to
chrissyright.com
get get a book so that when she launches
this on her instagram
um you can follow her you can connect
with her on instagram at christy b
wright again that's christy b wright so
that way you can be a part of this get
the book
and get on there because i'm telling you
right now christy wright got energy so
you're not going to be bored you're not
going to fall asleep
or lazy or slowing down she's going to
come with the energy and so and
you know what if it comes about living
true if you have any questions about
living true about balance life balance
uh give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five
we have another hour with you all today
four more segments or actually three
more segments after this
so we are here to answer your question
about uh money i've been teaching
uh the world today about what the
definition of securing the bag so secure
the battery
that's been the theme of today's show
yeah you know so about getting it
getting a check
making money and so if you have a
question about you know how to get more
money
how to get out of debt how to secure the
bag
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five uh daniel's with
us
in uh jackson mississippi uh daniel good
afternoon how can
chrissy and i help absolutely thank you
all for letting me come on
and uh i'll try to make this pretty
brief my question is i
am currently working through the steps
and
i'm about a month away from
getting baby step three and moving into
four
okay um and so basically i have
a positive cash flow of about three
thousand dollars a month okay
and uh my current financial advisor
has gone more the route of
encouraging heavy investment in uh 401k
and ross
okay basically to the point where i'm
not paying extra on my mortgage and i
know
the advice i've gotten so far is that uh
to do it the way you do 15 and then pay
down your house
uh is some people say safe money or
incredibly conservative
um but can you help me understand a bit
better the benefits of going that 15
route and paying down the home early
yeah yeah so let me ask you this
question how much is your your um
financial advisor telling you to invest
yeah so he's essentially uh 40
of my uh growth income so
uh he is out of that three thousand
dollars he's encouraging me to
invest uh 21.25 a month and how do you
listen
up i'm sorry i say again
i mean and how do you live off of that
right
yeah yeah no i agree and so here's the
thing i agree go ahead
what we teach daniel is we want you to
live comfortable we want you to live
below your means
um how old are you if you don't mind me
asking 21.
okay 29 so you're a young guy okay
you're young like christy and i
and so we have no problem with you uh
i have no problem with you even being
aggressive with your investing but what
i want you to do is first go ahead and
attack the 15 percent
and go ahead and pay off your mortgage
while you're doing that now once you pay
off your mortgage
and you're completely debt free baby
step number seven
is build wealth and give so if you want
to go back and up your investments
you have that option you can do that if
you want to go out there and start
purchasing some land start purchasing
some real estate
you can do that but right now the main
thing is start
investing in at the 15
minimum and then get very aggressive
with paying off your mortgage
so that way you can be 100 debt free
going into maybe your late 30s and your
early 40s
and if you and if you're married at that
time your spouse decided hey
let's invest some more over here or
let's do this with real estate or let's
open up this business
by all means you have the right to do
that because you're in the
the step that requires you or will not
require you but it's the step to build
wealth
and give but right now you're young i
would rather you focus on paying
off debt because i want financial
freedom um i want
bondage off of you and and so that's
what i would
really really focus on uh brother uh
because
yeah so i what i would suggest is to
interview another financial advisor i
will go to smartbesterpro.com go to
daveramsey.com
look up one of our smart investors don't
leave your financial advisor yet but
interview one of ours
uh you'll get about five phone calls
from five solid people who
i fully endorse christy fully endorsed
stay fully endorsed
and just have a conversation with them
and get get some other advice
because again i want you to grow doing
this process
i want you to build wealth during this
process but at the same time once you
get the right wisdom below this journey
and
yeah and it's a marathon daniel it's a
marathon not a sprint you want to enjoy
your life along the way you want to be
conservative
but you want to enjoy your life not have
you know nothing to live on and enjoy it
just because you're
you're investing so much oh yeah man
yeah
40 it's a great question i mean it's
good that he's asking that's cool
gotta ask it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had
chm chm saved our life same doctor
financial life
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance
but it is a budget friendly option and
the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
[Music]
taxes christy nobody wants to do them
but you know what we all have to do them
but with ramsey smart tax you finally
have an easy
money smart way to foul online the other
software out there
is not what it's cracked up to be let me
just be 100 with you all right
they say it's free but no turbo tax is
not free for the vast majority of people
who use it
they sign up racket up the price and
suddenly
free turns into forty dollars sixty
dollars even up to a hundred and twenty
dollars which is ridiculous
but you know what here ramsay solutions
we love our people and we don't jack
you around like that the cost to file a
federal return with ramsey smart tax is
crystal
clear 17 or 37
not 60 not 120 and depending on the
level of support you need
plus 32 dollars if you have to file
state taxes
and some folks don't just like tennessee
but listen it's not just about cost our
technology and support
we'll go toe-to-toe with turbo any day
of the week
and we will never let me say this again
we will never
leverage your financial situation to
sell you credit cards
and ridiculous loans like a lot of these
young people not young people like a lot
of these other companies do
sign up for smart tax uh for free and
take a
look around the software you won't pay
a thing till you are confident you've
got your taxes
right and you're ready to click file so
take out your phones right now actually
you should have your phones out right
now
if you're driving don't drive and text i
want you to text the word tax
t a x 3
that's tax tax two three three seven
eight nine let me tell you something
people use tax software thinking
these companies have their best interest
at heart
and they don't yeah and that's why they
are selling you all these credit cards
and all these ridiculous things and you
go to it and you think oh well they're
experts they're
financial experts they know taxes i can
trust them i should
get this credit card and man people are
making some mistakes
with their whole financial future
because of that they're leading them
astray that's why it's so important to
use
a company you trust that's why we want
to help you with this
yes yes i'm telling you right now um you
know
i actually filed through my account but
i mean if i didn't have one i would
definitely be using this
yeah you know because i mean it's clear
i'm i've actually walked through it
myself
um even on my youtube show to show
people how to do it and this is super
clear
and they ask you all the right questions
to make sure that you're filing
correctly
and you won't have any trouble uh
legally down the road that's so good
and so again i want to say this again i
want you to text the word tax
tax to 33789 and i promise you
you'll think ramsay solutions uh later
on we're gonna go out to arkansas and
talk to rachel rachel good afternoon how
can christy and i help
good afternoon how are you guys doing
well doing well thanks for calling in
how can we help
so i have my
like three to six months of emergency
fund and i'm just wondering
um how much is good like percentage-wise
for a down payment on a house
yeah yeah yeah that's a good question so
what we teach here at ram solutions has
baby set 3b
once you get once you are out of debt
once you have a fully funded emergency
fund you move over to 3b and you save
10 to 20 percent to put down on a home
now rachel the ideal situation is going
to pay for a cash but
a lot of us are not going to pay for a
cash i know i couldn't pay for mine cash
um be real right here in the ramsey show
and so
uh the bare minimum we say is 10 to 20
percent to put
down when are you looking to purchase a
home rachel
um in the near future
um my roommate situation is not like
ideal and i just also don't like the
fact that i just
keep putting money into rent and i'm not
really getting anything out of it
besides short term
yeah yeah yeah don't don't see and when
i hear people say this like oh man i'm
wasting money on rent no you're actually
saving money you know because
uh in the long term i get the philosophy
behind why you think like that
but renting allows you to set yourself
up to make the right decision
to purchase the home the right way so it
can be
it will save you a lot of money i know a
lot of people who will just do the
you know the fha loan 3.5 down get into
a house that they really can't afford
when they go to sell it they really
can't make any money off of it because
they didn't do it the right way so what
we teach here
is to save 10 to 20 to put down on a
home you're going to finance at a
15-year
fixed rate mortgage now some people say
well anthony that's a lot of money so
here's the thing when it comes to 20
rachel if you can put 20 down you have
20
equity inside of your home this is going
to help you avoid
a pmi private mortgage insurance all
right
and so if you are doing a private
mortgage insurance like what most
most fha loans do you're spending a lot
of money that doesn't go towards your
principal
or interest okay and we do not want you
to do that but here's the bare minimum
if you put down 10 the key thing here is
just make sure
that your mortgage payment is less than
25
of your take-home pay so put down that
if it's 10
15 okay cool great uh but the ideal
situation would be 20
so that way you can avoid pmi sounds
good
oh man thank you so much for calling in
i really do appreciate it
uh ryan is with us in fort wayne good
afternoon ryan how can christy and i
help
yeah so i kind of torn on
what to do as far as um housing
situation here so i'm on baby step two
and we're doing really really good
gazelle intensity feeling great
uh snapped all of our credit cards in
half cancelled them all
yeah uh should have about half my
student loans paid off by the end of
this year let's go
awesome yes i'm feeling great i was very
very blessed my income increased last
year and it's going to increase this
year as well too so
i got an email the other day saying that
the guesstimation i guess is what i'm
kind of calling it that the equity on my
house has gone up just from being there
for a couple years
and the equity is getting really close
to how much my student loans
are on the outstanding balances right
now
would it make sense to sell the home in
the next couple years if the equity gets
past it and then
rent to kind of streamline baby step
three or just keep going with the
gazelle intensity and build more equity
and just
be more patient that way when it comes
to baby step three
um you know i'll have more equity in the
house and if we do sell the house we'll
have that much more for
emergency funds investing et cetera et
cetera matt
such a great question ryan and um i love
the tone of your voice i hear the focus
um i hear it i hear the intentionality
inside of you
um the fact that you're willing to ask
this question about your home lets me
know that
that you and your family are very
serious about paying
off your debt so i want to commend you
and celebrate you for that
um let's just say right now that you had
no debt you had a fully funded emergency
fund
would you want to sell the house yeah
you will so you're not sold on this
house you don't love this house this is
not
love love we we do love the house the
thing is
we know the pro the family's probably
gonna expand in the future as well too
so we're gonna need more room okay um
but we got into this house at a really
really good price at a really really
good time in a really strong housing
market out here and it worked
in our favor just don't know if i should
just keep writing this momentum train
that i'm on
or uh get into baby step 3 quicker if
that means getting out of debt
sooner and just renting how much debt do
you have real quick
close to about 50. um 50 000.
how much equity is in your home it's
guesstimated between
38 040. okay yeah
um i'm going to stay in the house right
now same same thank you good
please
i'm staying in the house man i'm going
to stay in the house i'ma ride it
until the house can no longer fit me and
my family
fifty thousand dollars uh real quickly
what's your household income
combined between the wife and i so we
both work commission
so realistically we're gonna be about
130 this year if this year goes well
we'll probably be close to about 160.
yeah
you could be debt-free within the next
you know within the next
12 to 14 15 months if you all do this
and then here's the thing that's
interesting ryan sometimes when we get
so motivated we get so excited we're
like how can i fast track that and i get
it because i'm
wired the same way but what's
interesting is if you're not careful
you will get so excited you will make a
decision that just creates a different
set of problems for you
you then have to save up all over again
for a house you're renting you don't
like your landlord it's a headache
you're moving
and then you've got commissions and fees
and moves it's a different headache it's
not like you got rid of the problem you
just had a different problem so i would
say stay put
keep building equity just like ao said
get out of debt and then
do it patiently over time absolutely
that's right
y'all heard christie no chris no
you had it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i just love that music that our producer
aka dj
is playing right that have some good
music james thank you for that sir
i need you to bring you on to the table
with anthony o'neil
cause i like that music this is the
ramsay show triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five christy wright and
myself anthony o'neil
are here today to talk to you today
about your life your money
want to start a business whatever you
want to do give us a call we can talk
about relationships
normally chrissy when john deloney and i
on oh we get a lot of marriage
and relationship and boyfriend
girlfriend and should i move in
questions
we haven't gotten any of those i bet
that's a i bet that's a fun conversation
between you and delivery oh man
listen you know before the show my
producer our producer james came in and
said hey man you should be a little more
softer when you say
things you know i was like i understand
i can do that
if i try real real real hard and focus
he was like hey you shouldn't say that
because it can come off a certain kind
of way and i was like okay all right
cool great great great so you know what
we need to do next time we need to set
it up
and have people call in with faith
questions because i'm doing this devo
stuff right now you've got a church
background like we could just we could
just bring him to church
i feel like we could do that let's do it
next time we'll do that we got another
segment coming up after this if you have
any faith
questions um not really devo questions
because faith will even
to the devil but any faith questions
give us a call
next segment triple eight eight two five
five two two five let kelly know you got
a faith question
maybe she'll let you on maybe she won't
she's the boss
you know triple eight eight two five
five two two five andy is with us
in colorado springs oh good afternoon
andy i see you have a question for
christy talk to us
what's going on hi guys it's a pleasure
to
to speak to you today i i recommend dave
and his team
everybody and tell them i'd be a
millionaire three times overvoted known
he existed 10 years ago
you and everybody else right really
i've got um i've got a weird issue that
cropped up today okay
i i own a coffee shop in colorado
springs
and i got an email we have we use a um
a an app for scheduling called home base
and we received an email today that they
are rolling out something really
exciting for my employees they're going
to be offering my employees
the ability to get cash advances on
their pay
at no cost to me and it's wonderful for
them in case they need extra money
yeah what how many boys do you have i
have 19.
okay here's what i'm gonna do andy and
this is gonna sound drastic but it's
that important because i can hear your
voice this is
this is against your values period right
right yeah we're not going to use a
program that's against your values
period so here's what we're going to do
you're going to tell your 19 employees
which is
absolutely something you can manage on
your own
even if it is just means you write
checks to people for their paychecks for
a couple weeks
until you get a new program in place but
what i would do is i would go to the
leadership of that company and say i'm
canceling immediately
unless you take this off the table and
change this policy for my employees
if they will not back down then you
cancel and you let your team know you
send an email to your team and say hey
guys
i hate that this is happening we're
going to go with a new program we had
some differences
in leadership and values and we're just
not going to use a program you don't
have to go in the details of what it was
we're not going to use a program that's
uh against our values and we've done
that as a company just so you know andy
ramsey solutions has
absolutely pulled out i mean just
slammed on the emergency brake
with vendors companies that we've used
for different things the moment they try
to do something
that is not in line with our values that
there's no price
that is worth it when you're running
your company you're running it because
you want it to be in line with your
value so what i would recommend you do
is first reach out to the leadership of
that scheduling app
try to get on a phone call and say
either this is not being offered and i
will consider staying with you for
for you know the time being or if they
will not you immediately cancel
your relationship with them i don't care
if you use a google doc
to schedule your team members you got
19. we're not talking about 500 people
here you can manage the schedule
uh just for me it is 500.
yeah yeah i hear you but keep in mind
it's temporary right
it's going to be it may be a month maybe
you make their schedule
by hand in an excel spreadsheet or
google doc for a month and that's it
and and or even it might even just be a
few days till you find something
there's a million options out there you
just need enough time
to be able to find something that's
better and that's gonna take you a few
days to do that so you're buying
yourself a little time
with your team and just tell your team
whatever their schedule is how long have
they been scheduled out through
like what do they know through the
schedule two weeks in advance
okay okay you're fine they're set their
schedule set
their schedule set we're gonna pull out
of this company and figure out a
different option for you but i
absolutely would not let this roll out
to your team you will regret it it will
keep you up at night you will start to
hate yourself they aren't going to
regret it they are going to regret it so
much
and there's no like consequences and
they tell you we don't sell your
information but you know
as soon as they start borrowing
something's gonna something's gonna drop
yeah this is going to give you
everything in you that is like the red
flag alarms going off
is absolutely accurate and i want you to
listen to that
and i want you to go ahead even though
it may feel uncomfortable to do this it
feels like a knee-jerk decision
they're forcing you in this position and
and you need to do what's best for you
your company and your team members and
the best thing is to not allow this to
roll out worried that i was being more
of a dad than a boss
no no no no no no here's what's
interesting here's what's interesting
this is not about
you what you allow or don't allow for
your team members okay i want to
separate this for you really quickly
what you're not going to allow is for
your company
to have operations that are
perpendicular to your values
because your team members do not
separate you from the scheduling company
it's all you right it's all their
experience of their leadership and so
it's it's you endorsing this type of
action and you're not okay with that
this is not about you being a doctor i
don't mind giving like a i don't mind
giving anybody you know
an advance if they have a problem and i
figure out how they're going to pay back
so it doesn't hurt them and they can pay
their bills
but at least i have control over that
this this is going to be willy nilly
it's like giving a cookie to the mouth
yeah no we're not we're not going to do
it andy you got you got you're on the
right track you know what you need to do
you just need to follow through with it
let communicate to your team members
come up with the new plan they know
their schedules for two weeks they're
fine two weeks is plenty of time for you
to get something else in place
uh but nothing is worth you having your
company run your
your business run in a way that's
perpendicular to your personal values
that's why you started your company
so you could have a company in line with
your values and and you need to stick
with those
great question though i'm sorry that
happened man that stinks great question
sometimes yeah it does
uh blake is with us in texas good
afternoon blake uh real quick man you
have about a minute and a half uh
ask your question a question to christy
hey how's it going guys um hi me and my
fiance are on baby step two
uh and we started this about a week and
a half ago
uh we're down to just the vehicles and
the house but you know we're putting the
house
back and whatnot but um
i'm looking to start
my painting company back up again i had
it
a while back a couple years ago i
started it
and then i failed miserably partly
because the way i handled money
before i found dave ramsey and listened
to what he had to say and every everyone
in his
his studios had to say and started
taking that all in and
me and my fiance have been talking about
me starting it back out but i have a
full-time job i work 10 to 12 hours a
day
and i make about 60 000 a year where i'm
at
and i need a i'm trying to figure out
where at what point i can actually
stop and then start something new like
that
um to make it your full-time day to make
it my full-time thing without harming my
family
being my fiance and my my 10 month old
child
and how to make that transition smoothly
as possible
totally i hear you here's the thing
you're going to build it up on the side
in every hour that you can nights
weekends get creative
take as many jobs as you can for a while
it's going to feel like you're working
two full-time jobs maybe even three
because you are
but you're going to build up that income
enough that it can support you
financially that might mean getting
creative with your full-time job if
there's any way you can back off of some
of those hours or whatever your days and
schedule look like from a logistics
standpoint
but the way we say it is you want to
pull the boat close enough to the dock
that when you step in the boat that side
business it's not falling in the water
so you need to build up that money
that's why i love doing a show with
christy wright hey this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
today scripture and quote comes from
psalm 16
verse 11. you make known to me the path
of life in your presence there is
fullness of joy
at your right hand are pleasures
forevermore
pharaoh mcgalladen says do not follow
where the path may lead go instead where
there
is no path and leave a trail
i like that create your own journey and
let people
follow you well you know what we're
gonna get back to the phone calls and
and i gotta say man you know
christy today's been fun this is great
this has just really been fun i i like
doing the show with you
you know we gotta do this more we got a
lot of energy i love that about us i
love it
i love me some christy right we're gonna
go out to uh chicago illinois where it
is code
right now have a conversation with
travis travis hey man is it cold out
there
uh it's not too bad it's kind of warming
up
what's the weather travis i mean drivers
what's the weather man what's the
temperature
i'm sorry what's the temperature
um honestly i don't know for chicago
i'm a couple minutes out from there okay
okay all right all right all right
cuz you know y'all 40 here and you said
that
that's not too bad not for chicago
weather what's going on how can we help
oh my gosh
um so right now i work
40 miles away i have to
carpool with my friend to get there
because currently i don't have a vehicle
um i've got about 1500
saved up but i was wondering if i should
just buy a hoopkee or if i should
finance a very very
small loan
for a vehicle just so i can get there
safely and not have to worry about
breaking down
um i kind of feel like i already know
you guys answers but i just want a
reassurance
well um i'm pretty sure you know the
answer uh but i definitely do want to
you know i i want to say this and
america listen to me
we have to get out of saying buy a
hooptie buy a dave ramsey car
and just start saying let's buy a
reliable
car that will get me from point a to
point b that may not be my dream car
i believe in there there's power in what
we say and if we say it's a hooptie it's
going to become a hoop d and we're going
to treat it like it's a hoop t
and so uh drivers what i would
definitely say is yes
avoid student loans i get it oh man i'm
scared if i buy this fifteen hundred
dollar car this two thousand dollar car
it's gonna break down on me and you know
what the truth of the fact is
it might but so can a used car you know
any kind of used car i purchased a
beautiful high-end luxury car christy
about four months ago before i totally
doing this winter storm
and within not even a week of me having
a car
the car broke down and i had to take it
back to the shop so i think
for for for yourself man i would
definitely go out there and look
i would see if i can just sacrifice
maybe another month or two to get that
up to about maybe two to three thousand
dollars
and then look into a good reliable car
honda you know a honda product a toyota
product
a nissan product uh about maybe like a
2000
maybe like a 2010 acura tls are going
for right around
uh 5 000 if you get in high mileage of
about 150
and 150 on a honda product is is is
beautiful
it's just now getting started so what i
would just definitely do some research
man
um because i'm telling you right now you
can find you a reliable car
um i saw a uh a honda accord with 200
000 miles on it
uh chris and it was going for 3 200 and
a honda accord
2010 that is a good car that is a
reliable car
as long as you just keep the maintenance
up on it so drivers know stay away from
the debt
stay away from the debt do not finance
anything
right uh the only reason why i asked was
because like i said um
i do get a carpool with my friend and it
is about 40 miles there
um but he's going to be moving soon okay
and what i wouldn't have a ride there
anymore what soon
um well he doesn't really know honestly
but he's trying to get it within the
month
okay within a month all right cool so
then start looking start looking now you
have fifteen hundred dollars you can
find something
and just start looking you know but no
i'm not going to tell you anything are
there any public transportation options
from where you are
are you going into the city is there
anything like that
uh i believe so i think there's a train
but
i don't know uh the scheduling for it
yet because i work overnights
well the only reason i'm asking is
because here's what here's what i don't
like anthony i don't like
in anything in life when i feel like i
have two bad options and and so a car
loan
bad option or no car bad option so what
i would just encourage you to do
is just explore all your options get
super creative you still may not end up
going one of those routes but it's going
to make you feel more empowered
to go i've got five options and i'm
going to choose the best option
of these five options versus i've only
got two of them painted in a corner i
don't like
being in that position i don't think you
do either
and so if you look into this and you
realize okay the person i'm carpooling
with
it's actually going to be two months so
i've got more time and oh by the way
whenever i looked into the train
schedule they do have a train schedule i
could hop on that buys me another couple
months well how much could i save in
four months well maybe i could save an
extra four grand well now you're looking
at a really awesome five thousand dollar
car
man look how your opportunities have
opened up just because you explored
outside the box
of your two bad options it seems like
right now so i would just i would write
it down
look at all your options what
realistically are we talking about with
this carpool
friend what are the terrain options
public transportation is there anyone
else in your area you could carpool
could you put something on your
neighborhood facebook
post go hey does anybody work in the
city i go this way would you ever want
to carpool
just get creative get a little scrappy
and that's going to give you more
options to choose from and that's always
a good place to be
i love it thank you for doing it uh
saying that christy
uh let's oh man chris let me ask you
this question
in your and you're from your expertise
when people say they want to borrow
money to start a
business what do you tell them well i
tell them no
i know that comes as a huge shock to you
right now here's what i'll tell you that
i see when people ask this though
i see one of two things either one they
have been
told or somewhere along the way they
believe that they have to borrow money
to start a business
yeah and they believe that's okay
because they think what's not my loan
it's the businesses loan so it's not
really mine i'm not taking on debt it's
the business's debt and they think
somehow this is separate from them
and i remind them that someone has to
pay those bills and that someone is you
yeah
so it's still your debt and it's all a
bad idea so they have this belief that
the only way to start is to take out
loans and take out business loans and
that's okay and i always encourage them
you can start small grow slow
dave ramsey started this company on a
card table in his living room you can
start small and cash flow
the second thing i see and this is this
is
very common as well but it's just a
different angle on it
there are some people that don't really
need to take out debt
but because they're starting this
business and it's like this vulnerable
time for them like i'm excited i'm
nervous i've got this idea
let's say it's a i use a fitness coach
example or someone that wants to do hair
it's a salon
i'm so excited but but i've got to go
spend all this money buy all this
equipment you know lease a space
all these things they have to do yeah
they have to do it ao they say they have
to do it yeah like
they they can't be business and i remind
them
that they don't really have to do that
they don't have to buy those things and
more often than not they don't nine
times out of ten
here's what they're trying to do though
if you dig at their motivation
they want to buy something to make it
real to them
they want to buy something to validate
it's kind of like when i graduated
college
and i needed some new
suits to go interview for jobs as if i
didn't have
any perfectly fine interview clothes i
needed
a new laptop bag i didn't need that ao i
had clothes that were perfectly fine to
interview in but i wanted to like
validate or justify i'm in the workforce
i'm doing this
and i think a lot of people this
vulnerable stage of starting a business
they're trying to validate it and i just
remind them
buying stuff for your business doesn't
validate it money does
come on get money in your bank account
when you make a sale
your business is validated if you're in
your garage
working on a 1985 computer it's
validated with money's there and so i
just try to help people
bust the myths pull away the layers of
the lies they're believing to help them
understand what they really need to
start their business
which is tenacity and money not taking
out a loan or a bunch of equipment
you know what chrissy off subject but
you know what i needed a new suit
because my first job
interview was in a red suit with a
purple shirt
i was fired before i even did the
interview you actually don't need
something
merry christmas i want to thank christy
i want to thank our producer james child
and associate producer kelly daniel
in america remember the caliber of our
future our financial future will be
determined by the decisions we made
today
you made the right one by listening to
the ramsey show
[Music]
you